so today we'll be looking at exponential
functions
and the fact that they can be a bit
counterintuitive at times
um so if you don't mind um i'm going to
ask you a couple of questions to test
your intuition okay
okay warning all right
so you know that duckweed which is the
green stuff that grows on top of ponds
can grow quite rapidly and cover a pond
in
no time so let's say that we have a pond
and we introduce a little bit of
duckweed
on day one and in two weeks it will be
completely covered with
duckweed so how long does it take to
cover
half the pond with duckweed okay
i know so two weeks it's full is it yeah
um so i don't know
10 days 10 days no um
the trick is in the question it doubles
every day so on day 13
it was half full because it doubles and
then it's full
ah of course right yeah so what if
instead of starting with
one initial patch of duckweed we put an
equivalently sized one
on the other side of the pond and we let
it run
how long does it take to cover the
entire pond this time so i'm going to
say half because there are double the
amount of
plants make sense right but no again
it's 13 days because basically they both
have to cover a pond that is half the
original size
now let's go the other direction let's
imagine that the entire earth is covered
with fresh water how long would it take
to cover
the entire earth with duckweed there's a
there's a
trick inherent in this i can for sure
there is so it's not going to be very
long
a year or so a year or so i'll get to a
year in a minute so the first two weeks
we go
from about six square centimeters to
ten square meters that's covering the
entire pond in two weeks and then
another two weeks and it's enough to
cover the entire
campus of the university if it were
fresh water
another two weeks and it would cover all
of europe
and another week and it would cover the
earth now you were saying a year
and a year is actually plenty of time to
cover the entire galaxy
if it was covered in water in fact it
only takes 47 weeks to do so so our
intuition is kind of misleading with
exponential growth
and of course part of the reason is
because in practice there's always going
to be a barrier
the pond is only 10 square meters so
it's not going to grow beyond that
you know for humans that make sense
we're in an environment where things
eventually have to slow down another
example of this of course is a current
hot topic
the chronovirus which
has an initial growth that is also
thought to be
exponential of course at some point
there will be a break
because a lot of people will be immune
or you know shielded otherwise
say a vaccine so of course i'm not a
health expert i'm just talking about the
exponential growth bit here
and not about all the other things that
are
important for corona so the idea
is that there's a growth factor which is
sometimes called the
r zero and this r zero value
is the basis of the growth
so the duckweed was growing with a
factor two
every day now the r0 value is not
defined over a specific period of time
but rather over the infectious period so
if your r0 is 3 what it means is that
the average person over their term of
being infectious
will infect three others so by the time
they're better
they will on average have infected three
others now if that infectious period is
about a week
that means that every week the number of
patients will triple
and this is sort of what we saw in the
beginning of the corona
virus crisis so what the duckweed and
the coronavirus
have in common is that they follow
exponential growth
and i think it's a good idea to train
our intuition
to write down a very simple formula so
let's
derive this formula um specifically at
first
for the duckweed in the pond right we
know that there's an initial value i
already
said the value so let's just write it
down the initial value was
six squared centimeters and then after
the first day
it doubled so that's a times two
after the second day it doubled again
times 2.
now of course we need to do this 14
times i'm not going to write down 14
twos but you get the idea so we have 14
times this doubling process now
i think almost everyone will be aware of
a different way
of writing this down which is simply to
say
we have the six square centimeters times
two to the power 14.
and 2 to the power 14 is roughly
sixteen thousand sixteen thousand three
hundred roughly
and if we multiply these two numbers
what we get
is a hundred thousand square centimeters
so remember that's the original unit so
this remains the unit and it
means that it's 10 square meter we all
know that exponential growth
has an exponent there's no surprise
there but we can generalize
away 6 was our initial value so we write
that down with the letter
i to we call our base
so in our case it was doubling every
time period
so that's our base b in our case two the
we denote with t
so that is 14 days and then the result
will be our final value and this is
how all exponential growth works you
have an initial value
times the amount of change per time unit
to the power time units is equal to our
final value now another example of
exponential growth that we're all
familiar with
are of course bank accounts and accruing
or paying
interest
so in this case the growth is often
expressed as a percentage
so how do we convert a percentage to a
base so let's say that we have
three percent growth so obviously that
is not the same as
tripling every time period so we don't
want to fill in three for b
here we want to convert this to a number
that fits there
so three percent growth means that if
you have a hundred percent
after one time period you'll have a
hundred and three percent
um so it also means that if you have one
unit and you have three percent growth
you'll have one point zero three units
so what you do is you add 100 to get 103
and you divide all of that by 100 to go
from a percentage to a number
and the value you end up with is 1.03
we talk about exponential growth and the
immediate thought is a
huge amount of growth when actually i'm
thinking three percent
not so great exactly and this is the
point
i was about to make it's not very
intuitive um
perhaps that's part of the reasons why
banks like to use percentages
because they're not very intuitive which
works in their advantage
if someone says monthly interest of
three percent you might think that's not
a lot
but if you convert it to annual interest
it's actually
really a lot there's another way to
think about this because you can convert
bases so instead of saying we want to
have 1.03
so let's say that you have 10 000 pounds
on your bank account
and a 3 interest and you're running it
over let's say 10 years so this is one
way
to approach it i don't know by heart
what the answer is but
this will be the amount of money you
have on your bank account
after 10 years of 3 but another way to
think about this
is how long does it take to double my
money
so you want to find a value x such that
1.03 to the power x
is equal to 2. and it turns out you can
use a logarithm to compute this
that x is roughly 23
and a half years so that means that
after 23 and a half years of accruing 3
interest you will have doubled
your money now if you have two percent
interest
it will take you 35 years um
so i recommend and a lot of people do
this when they ask for a mortgage
is they convert these figures to how
long does it take
to double the money or to pay off the
principal
etc etc so that's basically what you're
doing you're converting the base
and the time period from one format to
another
in computer science we typically use
two as the base anyone can guess why
right
binary stuff 2 to the power makes sense
so a famous
exponentially hard problem in computer
science
is the towers of hanoi in case you don't
know what the towers of hanoi is
you have a game where you have three
prongs
and you have discs that can slide onto
the prongs
and there's one rule in one rule only
which is bigger discs cannot go onto
smaller discs so they always have to
have a shape like this
and now the trick is can you move
a number of disks from one prong to the
other prong
without breaking this rule so if you
have
two disks for example you can take the
top disc
put it in the middle take the bottom
disc move it to the right
then take the smaller disc and put it on
top
it gets a lot more complicated if you
have more discs well it's not more
complicated but it gets a lot more
involved at least
and let's try to figure out why
so let's say that i give you a way to
move k disks
so any number k disks i give you a way
to move them now i ask you can you move
k plus 1 disks
and the answer is actually yes quite
easily
because you take the top k disks you
move them away
using the known way the bottom disc
you can move it now because it's free
and then you take again the k
disks and you move it on top of the now
moved
bottom disk now this algorithm is very
nice
but it has the downside that you had to
do the moving the
tower of k disks twice so every time you
add one disk
you need to do the problem for the
previous one twice
so we can actually write down the
formula for this
um so we know that it doubles every time
you add a disk
so the base is 2 again computer science
and then the number of disks let's call
that
n so 2 to the power n that's how much
time it costs
now what we notice here is that
time is actually our final value and the
number of disks
is our exponent so it's kind of flipped
um
from the problems we've seen before but
that's perfectly fine
our initial value is how long it takes a
computer to move a single disk
so let's say that you build a computer
program to do towers of hanoi you can
ask torsten how to do it in one of the
computer file videos but let's say that
it takes
about a billionth of a second because
the computer can do
dozens of operations in that time that
is
1 nanosecond and then
you can do 2 to the power n operations
and that will be our
final value now we are free to fill in a
value
n and ask ourselves how long will it
take a computer so if we fill in
a reasonable value like 10 2 to the
power 10
is 1024 so that's a nice value because
it's roughly a thousand so that means
that we can do
10 disks a computer can do 10 disks i
can't
in one millionth of a second it can do
20 disks
in a thousandth of a second it can do 30
disks
in a second okay so you think okay
that's fairly quick 30 disks
per second but then if we move to 40
disks it will
take a thousand seconds which is you
know almost 20 minutes
then if you move to 50 disks well you
get a thousand times 20 minutes
so that's in the order of magnitude of
several weeks
then if you go to 10 more
60 discs you'll get again a thousand
times that time span
which will be in the order of magnitude
of centuries already
and then of course if you go beyond that
you know before you reach 100 discs
the universe will have died a black
death or
whatever it's called nowadays a big
crunch um there's just no way that a
computer
will be able to compute this but then
you might say okay what if
we make the computers a bit faster right
what if
we instead of having a gigahertz
computer we have
a petaherd computer
so it will be a thousand times quicker
well all that means
is that it can do 10 disks more than the
previous computer
you might say what if we are smart in
the algorithm and we have some shortcuts
and we can save 99
99 okay that's a factor 100 so that
means that you can save
about six or seven disks and this is the
big problem of exponential
algorithms in computing now in the case
of the towers of hanoi it's not a
practical problem because why on earth
would you want a computer
to to tell you exactly which disks to
move for 100 disks that just doesn't
happen
but there are famous problems that we
believe are exponential
that are of interest a famous example is
a traveling salesman problem
so let's say that you want to visit say
20 cities in the uk
and you ask yourself can i do this in
one week
you know following you can use public
transport you can use the car
whatever can you do this in a week and
in general
there's no easy way of finding this
answer one naive way to do this would be
to look at all combinations of cities
and that is exponentially many
combinations so that means that if you
add one city
you have to now consider all
permutations that include this
one city so that means that it will be
more than two times as hard
every time you add one city to the
problem and that of course
is going to run into the same issues
here it doesn't really matter what the
initial value is it doesn't really
matter what the base is
if you have an exponential function
it will always get out of hand at some
point
now in the case of the traveling
salesman problem this is a bad thing
because we would like to be able to
compute
you know faster ways of traveling that
would be nice wouldn't it but in the
case of computer security
it is actually a good thing sometimes
that it's difficult to compute certain
problems
if you have for example a 2048-bit key
what it means is that there's two to the
power
2048 different key possibilities so if
you start guessing keys
you can go multiple runs of the universe
just guessing random keys and you'll
never
even get close to getting the right key
that is the nature of exponential
distributions
they can go up really quickly much more
quickly than we can understand
thinking about it naively but by simply
looking at a formula we can get
more informed uh ideas of the
speed of the growth i'm hoping one day
my bank account interest will get out of
hand that's the
that's the hope yes so i don't know if
you've seen futurama but
if you have a thousand years worth of
interest you have a lot of money
unfortunately the world government will
have collapsed a couple of times so
it still ends up worthless
here this one back so i know the trick
huh
this one here ha and it all works out
which is keeping track of time in that
way we'll get
really confused and we basically get the
millennium bug
all over again there must be a way of
fixing this are people working on it
already
you